thank you for joining us America we're
glad you are here in the lobby of ramsy
solutions Dave and terara are with us
hey guys how are you hey Dave good how
are you welcome I like your t-shirts got
some gazelle shirts on for those of you
that can't see through your radio you're
watching on YouTube or whatever love
them very cool so you're here to do your
Deb free scream we are where you from
Wellington Florida right outside of West
Pond oh cool very nice and uh how much
debt have you paid off
17,7 161
$761 59 good job all right very nice how
long did that take 28 months that's
quick range of income during that time
we started around 80 and through this
process in the 28 months we're about at
130 wow substantial raises where did the
raises come from uh just just work stuff
and God just blessing this whole thing
wow very cool excellent what do you guys
do for a living I'm in Human Resources I
work for a Healthcare Company mhm and
Tara I was working in payroll and then
slowly I've moved to being back at home
with the kids okay very cool good that's
neat yeah so what kind of debt was the
108,000 oh Lord bad decisions credit
cards two cars um we had some medical
bills that ranged back to our older son
when he was in his teens um we we were
just continuously making bad decision
after bad decision in fact the the
Friday before we took Financial Peace
University I was at a dealership ready
to buy a new car I didn't know I was
taking financial piece by the way I had
no idea um terara signed us up and I
kind of went and she just announced to
you here we go she signed up in church
and said hey by the way um I'm going to
financial piece and if you want to come
along you know come along and want to
stay married you'll come along and I
mean
yeah awesome okay so you guys into class
Tara what made you sign up for financial
peace I just heard about it so long ago
about 18 years ago my brother-in-law and
my sister kind of told us about you and
it's always been on my heart and I kept
asking Dave you want to come and he's
like no absolutely not I do not want to
do that I know where my money's going
mhm and finally I just said I had it I'm
going and so you can either come or you
can just pick me up after but I need to
learn some more about this cuz we're
just going backwards that's known as the
Holy Spirit telling me to show
up I got you brother I got you so you
wander into class a bit reluctantly to
say the least uh and maybe even more
than a little bit and uh so how did the
first class go well I had my back to the
whole table we had a table of 10 our uh
our one of our pastors is sitting at our
table going through it I'm sure that not
I'm sure everyone that that took that
class said man we didn't think you're
going to make it the week two cuz I was
just mad but inside it was stirring like
I don't know what I'm doing I I've made
bad decisions it's time to change my my
future so wow here we are so you roll
into you roll into the next week ready
ready to go a little bit more huh I I I
was still acting like I didn't want to
be there okay until week three but I did
have fun with the the free spirit part
and the you know the nerd part that
that's where I I just hooked on and went
and and changed our lives so it just
started sense and really God's spirit
was just working on yeah changed our
marriage man changed it I bet very cool
how long you guys have been
married 22 years wow yeah neat neat we
just knocked 34 out the other day so
we're a little ahead of you yes but very
cool well congratulations and then uh so
then then you you know as you uh week
three hits uh so now you're really
starting to get on board and uh then you
go okay we're going to do this and Tara
I have a feeling
that when Dave does something he doesn't
sort of do something he does it all the
way am I right yep that's kind of cuz he
like didn't sort of didn't want to go
he's not real pliable he just whatever
he's going to do he's going to do right
or wrong right definitely yeah so when
he's in he's in so now it's it's wide
open I'm guessing that's right that's
right and and we teach it and you know
we're very involved with it so now you
teach the class that's awesome God has a
sense of humor doesn't he cuz awes I
never would have guessed I'd be teaching
Financial Peace in a million years which
church are you in we're at Christ
Fellowship oh are you okay all right
yeah we love those guys they're awesome
very good good friends really good folks
yeah all right fun and that's thus the
gazelle t-shirts for being coordinator
that's right that's right yep very neat
fun so now that you're teaching it and
you've come the full circle from being
the ultimate reluctant spouse you know
all the way around what is your advice
to people who want to get out of debt
what are the what are the main things
they have to know don't wait don't wait
because um you mention it in class it's
it's it it could save your
marriage and um it did
ours um listen to the principles but put
God first and when you put God first
amazing things happen wow and and you
turn into a selfless instead of a
selfish person wow yeah very cool and
don't look at that number that that big
number cuz we were like way at the
bottom of the class
but don't look at that number and say I
can never get to that number because
we've just made a chart and we said
we'll start the first month was like
this much and finally we got to the top
of the chart and that's what kept us
going and doing our budget don't waver
from it do it do it do it every month in
fact we adopted Proverbs 10:4 it says
lazy hands make for poverty but diligent
hands bring wealth or Prosperity MH so
we've adopted that we teach it that way
absolutely and we're seeing lives change
all over our church man it's awesome
that's very very cool very cool yeah so
Tara how much of a change have you seen
in this guy I hear all the emotion in
his voice so much it's really awesome to
see and to see where we were and where
we are today and just a tad over two
years yeah I mean that's amazing huge
turn around we we projected August to be
done mhm but our son was coming here for
a band camp a Christian band camp oh
cool and we said well we're going to be
in Tennessee so everything we had we
just put everything into our final bill
the last two months like we've had no
spending money we haven't done anything
I gave plasma for money to come on
vacation I mean here I am making 100
plus and I'm giving plasma for money but
you do what you got to do to get past
past the next school cuz we want to get
to step three and we still want to buy a
home cuz we had a short sale home some
years ago wow yeah now uh your son's
with you what's his name and how old is
he JT and he's 14 all right so you're
how many kids have you got three 24 21
and 14 all right so JT's watched all
this happen yeah big time he has he been
seeing really what's going on or is he
just watching from a distance he's
seeing it and he's on a um he's on his
own little budget trying to uh get his
guitar you know his budget for his
guitar that he wants and he's trying to
work that way and he also is on
commission plan so when he does his
chores he gets paid when he doesn't he
doesn't get paid I hear you he loves FPU
for that
part well it gives him a track to run on
that's yeah it does well well done you
guys I'm very very proud of you you're
Heroes man and more than that even more
than that you turn around teaching other
people that's just very very cool we
love it neat story all right Dave and
Tera and JT from West Palm Beach Florida
that's right
108,000 paid off in 28 months making 80
to 130 a year count it down let's hear a
debt free scream ready 3 2 1 we're debt
free
Yeah Baby
Woo way to go you guys that is awesome
very
nice you know I I'll never forget the
first day I was teaching the class I
used to teach it live Financial Beach
University with a overhead projector in
a bad suit and the first day this this
couple stopped me in the hall after that
the class is over and they said you know
you saved our marriage and I went wait
minute this is a financial class we're
talking about mut ual funds and budgets
and they said no you taught us how to
work together and how to how to talk
about this stuff and I went I did and I
kept hearing that over and over and over
and over and it's turned out to be one
of the biggest benefits of Financial
Peace University is the impact on
people's marriages for those that are
married those that are single obviously
it gives you control and other things
but not only getting out of debt and
being on a budget but it forces you to
work together and it forces so many
couples to heal broken spots in their
relationships it's so powerful God
really uses it in that way this class is
taught All Over America you need to get
in one if you havn't been through it
what are you waiting on oh my goodness
just go to De ramsey.com get signed up
it's time people it's your time this is
the Dave Ramsey Show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the Subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
your broke friends think you've lost
your mind
[Music]